Обдирають скажено військових, які на даний час
не мають змоги заплатити таких коштів.
Коли тебе зустрічають друзі, знайомі, навіть, ті самі родичі, вони тобі кажуть "тримайся".
За що ти маєш триматися? Ми можемо знайти інші слова.
Жінка сама залишається з цим. Їй дійсно дуже важко, безсило, і, звісно, потрібна підтримка.
Ветерани, вдови загиблих воїнів та родичі чинних військовослужбовців.
Усіх цих людей об'єднує не лише війна, яка повністю змінила їхнє життя.
Це - українці, які хочуть допомагати таким самим, як вони: юридично і психологічно.
Вони стали працівниками першого міського ветеранського хабу у Львові,
де консультують виключно люди з ветеранського середовища.
Оксаночко!
Кожного відвідувача цього центру у Львові першою зустрічає Наталія,
одразу запрошуючи на каву в окрему вітальню.
Вона - адміністраторка хабу та фахівчиня з допомоги родинам загиблих воїнів.
Зараз у центрі вона консультує, як оформити необхідні документи
і морально пройти той шлях, який сама пройшла торік,
коли дізналася про зникнення чоловіка-військового під Бахмутом.
Наші серця билися в унісон. Я залишилася сама.
У невідомості сьогоднішнього, майбутнього, минулого.
14 лютого 2023 року він зник безвісти. Це все дуже складно.
Документи всі подані відповідно до зразків, відповідно до дорожньої карти.
І далі складні місяці очікування.
Я не одна така, дівчат таких багато.
Діти, вони перші рази дуже тяжко переносять…
Після смерті чоловіка вона дуже до мене прив'язалася.
Вона ще ніде без мене не була.
Сьогодні у центр прийшла дружина загиблого захисника, яка тепер сама виховує двох дітей, як і Наталія.
Ми одна-одну розуміємо. Оце розуміння підсвідоме - це не пояснити словами.
Це просто ти приходиш і знаєш, що ти потрапила в таке середовище, де всі такі, як ти.
Коли тебе зустрічають друзі, знайомі, навіть, ті самі родичі, вони тобі кажуть "тримайся".
За що ти маєш триматися?
Дівчата, з якими ми зустрічаємося, їм теж оця фраза "тримайся" дуже важко дається.
Ми можемо знайти інші слова. Ми можемо поплакати.
Ми можемо обійнятися. І це все зближує!
Оксані потрібна консультація: слід оформити виплати і пільги на неповнолітню доньку.
Наталія пропонує їй кілька програм, якими користуються її діти.
Танюша вже має 8 років, тобто щорічно на поточний рік ви можете подати заяву
у ЦНАПі на оздоровлення дитини.
Ще одна особливість ветеранського хабу - це робота у комплексі з міським ЦНАПом,
який розташований у сусідньому крилі будівлі.
Ми не кажемо, що вам потрібно їхати в іншу частину міста для того,
щоб вирішити ту чи іншу проблему. Її можна вирішити тут.
Центр лише нещодавно запрацював. Крім родичів військових,
сюди також активно звертаються ветерани: як зі Львова, так і з регіонів.
Найчастіше їхні питання стосуються відсутності виплат від держави.
У мене, наприклад, затримка. Протягом двох років. Я не можу достукатися,
щоб мені ті гроші були виплачені. Тут просто в звичайній обстановці можна поговорити.
Ми просто накидаємо на комп'ютері, яка має бути заява звернення, і будемо працювати далі.
Як ветеранам відстояти свої права, у центрі консультує Віталій.
За фахом він юрист, під час повномасштабної війни пішов до лав ЗСУ,
після поранення демобілізувався і сам як ветеран зіткнувся з численними бюрократичними перепонами.
Є дуже багато зараз військових адвокатів, військових юристів.
Просто обдирають скажено військових, які на даний час не мають змоги
заплатити таких коштів, просто за подачу рапорту чи написання якоїсь ефективної заяви.
А в нас це можна зробити безкоштовно. Була вже не одна така справа,
у якій ми добилися виплати коштів. Я пройшов це, все цю "кухню", можна так сказати.
Відвідувачам хабу надають не лише юридичну підтримку. У сусідніх кімнатах щодня
проводять індивідуальні сеанси психотерапії. Лілія - одна з психологинь.
Двоє чоловіків у її родині захищають Україну в складі ЗСУ.
Тож вона знає з власного досвіду, не лише з історій підопічних, як війна впливає
і на воїнів, і на родичів, до яких вони повертаються з фронту.
Відбувається розрив між воїном і жінкою. Психологічний розрив,
тому що у нього зовсім уже інші цілі й інший фокус. І сім'я відходить на другий план.
І жінка сама залишається з цим. Їй дійсно дуже важко, безсило, і, звісно, потрібна підтримка.
Мені важливо якось бути долученою до допомоги людям.
До психолога можна, якщо щось трошки поганенько. Бо тут є таке різне.
Буває таке, що трошки агресія якась. Так, нормально, поспілкувалися.
Трошки легше, вже буде спатися краще.
Колишній військовий Ігор відвідує психотерапевта у центрі вже не вперше.
Каже, зручно суміщати вирішення правових питань з терапією.
А ще - вони з побратимами організовують тут профорієнтаційні зустрічі ветеранів
і просто ходять сюди поспілкуватися і випити чаю.
Ігор бачив, як подібні центри працюють в країнах НАТО, де він раніше бував.
Він переконаний: такий формат державних хабів треба поширювати всією Україною.
Місце дуже потрібне! Тому що оце наше спілкування ветеранське.
Ми от, наприклад, їздили в Польщу, побачили: там взагалі такий розмах, для тих ветеранів все!
У нас тільки започаткувалося, тож того не було так дуже. Воно йде помаленьку, йде.
Більше таких центрів на даний час немає. Збільшуватися, масштабуватися,
тобто, щоб людям було комфортніше добиратися по місцю проживання.
Тобто в кожному районі, якщо буде, це буде легше набагато.
Поки такий хаб у Львові один. У графіку роботи центру також майстер-класи
для дітей ветеранів, групова терапія для дружин військових, літературні вечори і концерти.
Конференц-зал, де ми проводимо різні розвиваючі навчальні процеси.
Наприклад, цієї суботи в нас була зустріч вдів.
Світлана Ткачук - директорка центру. Про такий формат міського хабу жінка думала
ще з 2016 року після того, як сама стала вдовою захисника - танкіста ЗСУ, який загинув на Донбасі.
Коли це сталося, звичайно, що я, як і всі подібні мені жінки, десь потребувала якогось
дійсно того самого середовища. Приїхавши сюди у Львів, у нас тут ні родичів не було,
друзі були тільки військові. Мені, по суті, не було куди йти і звертатися,
крім цього середовища, бо вони дійсно розуміють, підтримують, де є з ким поплакати.
У Львові та в інших обласних центрах України за останні 10 років з'явилося
чимало держцентрів з надання послуг ветеранам та їхнім родичам.
Однак це здебільшого заклади, де лише оформлюють документи і працюють люди,
недотичні до бойових дій. Львівська міська влада першою підтримала ідею активістів
ветеранської спільноти створити за бюджетний кошт комплексний центр для ветеранів,
де головна умова працевлаштування персоналу - особистий досвід служби в ЗСУ
або спілкування з військовими в родині. Набір у штат в хабі триває.
Найбільш затребувані - юристи, психотерапевти та івент-менеджери.
Непросто знайти таких спеціалістів, які мають особистий життєвий досвід,
дотичність до цього середовища, ну і плюс відповідну освіту.
Хочу залучати й інтенсивно шукаю, тому що ми розуміємо, що відвідуваність у нас буде рости.
Кількість мобілізованих зараз, напевно, у вісім разів, а то, можливо, і в десять більша,
ніж тих учасників бойових дій, які були у нас за період АТО та ООС.
Люди, які бачать ці фотографії, вони бачать просто фотографії.
Я бачу живу історію, яку прожила сама. Пан Василь має коней.
Відповідно він реабілітує наших хлопців. Цей хлопчик був з полону звільнений, опришко…
Наталія показує DW галерею фотографій, що прикрашає вхід у хаб.
Це ветерани Львова, які звертаються у центр.
Їхні історії жінка знає напам'ять. Каже, вони для неї - немов родина.
Коли людина проходить повз тебе, повз центр, ти вибігаєш на вулицю і кажеш:
"Доброго дня! Як ваші справи?". Бо ти прив'язаний до тих людей
, ти живеш разом з ними, проживаєш разом з ними це життя…